cet après-midi m nicole a plaidé avec
conviction il débute par un hommage à
ses adversaires ce dossier dit il
résulte d'un minutieux travail d'avocat
pour faire bouger la justice en tant
qu'avocat j'en suis fier mais à partir
du moment où l'adn de pascal jardin a
été identifié avocats et policiers de
chercheurs de vérité qu'ils étaient sont
devenu chasseur la proie
on l'aura compris c'est l'accusé dès
lors le travail de maître nicole est de
faire percevoir aux jurés ce qu'il nomme
une erreur méthodologique
on prend des ingrédients dans la réalité
pour construire une certitude
déplore-t-il
au centre de ces démonstrations les
aveux de pascal jardin il y à un fossé
entre ce qu'on entend dans
l'enregistrement est ce qu'on lit dans
la déposition rédigé par le policier
rien et spontanée dans ses aveux les
experts ils construisent la personnalité
de l'accusé à partir du dossier du crime
maître nicole demande le meurtre est
prouvé par quoi spontanément on répond
par le violent il y à m
parce qu'il y avait eu viols mais ça
n'est qu'une déduction on ne sait rien
de leurs de la mort de christelle dans
cette affaire il y a eu des loupés et
les loupés sont irrattrapables même avec
le miracle de l'adn et il conclut en
s'adressant aux jurés
il n'y a pas de preuves matérielles du
viol il n'y a pas de preuves matérielles
de qui est l'auteur du crime
vous pouvez donner coûte que coûte un
visage à ce crime
moi je vous demande de résister à ce
qu'on vous présente comme une évidence
et d'acquitter pascal jardin